this show is  number one not only in the  right leaning  uh as far as a demographic of you  but even in comparison to every single  network comedy show in the demographic  you  period it's not even close there are  more of you viewers and listeners in  this demo who tune into this than any  other show of this kind that exists  there isn't even a distant second period  now i we have been blessed with that  um  blessed with what i consider  incredible influence and opportunity by  the good graces of  you  and as much as  we do some really silly stuff granted i  don't take that i don't take that part  lightly and and finally and this is  i would say personally  possibly the most important  because of how much you  uh mean to me  person watching listening to the show  this will be